[Música]
bienvenidos a la serie de france 24
con motivo del día del reciclador que se
celebra el primero de marzo dedicamos
este programa a los trabajadores y
trabajadoras que hacen una labor
indispensable pero en su mayoría
invisible una tarea que tiene
implicaciones económicas pero sobre todo
sanitarias y medioambientales con la
necesidad como denominador común
millones de personas se dedican a
rescatar lo que muchos desechamos
considerándolo basura y este rescate de
materiales sucede casi siempre en
condiciones peligrosas precarias e
insalubres poco a poco y gracias a la
lucha comunitaria algunos de éstos están
consiguiendo hacerse oír todos los
reportajes que verán a continuación
hacen parte de la serie de publicaciones
que resultan de la beca de producción
periodística sobre reciclaje inclusivo
ejecutada con el apoyo de fundación gabo
y latitud r
el mundo de la basura y del reciclaje es
percibido como un sector para hombres
una percepción que quisieron cambiar en
argentina donde las mujeres han logrado
abrirse camino liderando el cambio para
lograr mejores ingresos protección
social y condiciones de salud una lucha
que benefició a toda la comunidad de
recicladores
aunque los recicladores en argentina son
una comunidad exhibida e invisibilizada
como en toda latinoamérica en la ciudad
de buenos aires- su historia cambió
gracias a la lucha de cooperativas
lideradas por mujeres como cristina
lescano fundadora del señor la primer
lucha nuestra fuerte malas prácticas y
constructivas y después bueno viene todo
lo demás rompimos un mito era un laburo
de hombres
y es el día de hoy que los empresarios
los compradores buscan a un hombre para
para hablar y se chocan con nosotras hay
quienes encontraron en el reciclado no
sólo una forma de vivir sino también de
conocer y asumir el feminismo como
jackie flores creadora del primer cuerpo
de promotoras ambientales en la ciudad
de buenos aires cuando me toca ser
responsable de la descarga una mujer
cuando siendo a 40 compañeros entre
choferes y operarios fue una experiencia
que me marcó una experiencia valiosa
para mí para empezar a profundizar el
feminismo popular muchas son líderes de
cooperativas e intentan mejorar las
condiciones de los 15 mil recicladores
que trabajan en la ciudad y más de 150
mil en todo el país
maría castillón fué cartonera y hoy está
a cargo de la dirección nacional de
reciclado nosotros llamamos wardak a
poner trabajo darle insumos que son
caros y bolsones guantes porque de ser
con más sensación para que ellos ese
valor agregado que quedan con las
herramientas puede aumentarlo
directamente en industria mejor precio
con su lucha ellas lograron más derechos
para los recicladores pero aún queda
mucho por mejorar faltan leyes de
responsabilidad extendida que impulsa en
el reciclado con inclusión social un
mayor financiamiento para las
cooperativas de recicladores y educación
ambiental para que los ciudadanos se
paren residuos en origen
pasamos ahora a la capital de colombia
donde los recicladores comenzaron en el
año 2013 con un proceso de formalización
que les permite recibir una parte de los
impuestos del aseo un indicador de
inclusión único en latinoamérica aún así
estos trabajadores ganan muy por debajo
del salario mínimo colombiano que ronda
tan sólo los 220 dólares al mes
los seres creadores de bogotá han visto
mejorar significativamente sus
condiciones de trabajo estos últimos
años estos son miembros de una de las
160 organizaciones de recicladores de la
capital colombiana ahora son reconocidos
oficialmente como prestadores del
servicio público de reciclaje
ahora significa mucho porque por lo
menos podemos presentarnos más tranquila
desconozcan soy recicladora y seguiré mi
farners o seas artística muchas cosas y
es un orgullo tener de formal pero el
mayor reconocimiento no es el más
visible los 16.000 recicladores de
bogotá miembros de una organización
tienen desde 2013 dos fuentes de
ingresos
la principal viene de la venta del
material que recolectan la segunda se
llama tarifa de aprovechamiento una
retribución pagada por los habitantes de
bogotá dentro de la factura de aseo en
el caso de lady representa entre 25 y 30
dólares mensuales el 20 por ciento de
sus ingresos
igualmente la tarifa también es
voluntaria son pues porque nos ayuda
para los vasos de la pasa bastante este
sistema es único en américa latina para
obtenerlo los recicladores colombianos
enfrentaron al estado colombiano ante la
corte constitucional
nora padilla fue la cabeza de este
movimiento la corte constitucional le da
la razón a los recicladores y no
solamente orden a la protección del
oficio en manos de los recicladores
lo que además ordena que se haga una
remuneración a los recicladores porque
lo que nosotros hacemos es lo mismo que
hacen las otras empresas privadas que
era recoger basura pero este complemento
de ingresos sigue siendo insuficiente
para sacar a los tres creadores de la
pobreza la mayoría de ellos ganan menos
de doscientos dólares mensuales por
debajo del salario mínimo colombiano
y del sur del continente americano desde
colombia pasamos ahora hasta
centroamérica en el salvador en el país
más pequeño de esta región el reciclaje
se ha convertido en una oportunidad de
trabajo para los jóvenes salvadoreños y
en una forma de alejarse de la violencia
de las pandillas los recicladores ahora
esperan que tal y como sucedió en
colombia llegue a la formalización de su
labor
y dedicarse al reciclaje para estos
jóvenes que trabajan en un centro de
acopio de desechos en la capital de el
salvador representa una oportunidad
digna para pagar sus estudios y tener un
mejor futuro de vida para mí sería sacar
una diaria
era lo que
mismo solo que haya en diferente forma y
a conocer colombia
como la vida de gracias
ya que es muy diferente
según datos del banco mundial la pobreza
ha ido disminuyendo en estos últimos
años en el salvador pero todavía los
jóvenes salvadoreños sufren de la falta
de oportunidades laborales y algunos
caen en la violencia de las pandillas
jóvenes como rodrigo encuentran en el
reciclaje una forma de vivir legal y
alejada de esa violencia
así como para nosotros los jóvenes es
algo complicado pero como ahí también
depende de la persona de lo que anda
haciendo así como nosotros nosotros no
andamos así en cosas ilícita entonces no
tenemos que preocuparnos si nos sale o
no nos sale así nos sale bueno yo nos
protege porque él sabe lo que andamos
haciendo con trabajo digno en 2020 tras
13 años de lucha entró en vigor una ley
integral de gestión de desechos sólidos
la nueva ley podría formalizar entre
3000 y 5000 recolectores también abrirá
un camino más en la formalidad para
rodrigo michelle y sus compañeros
en la ciudad más grande de latinoamérica
la labor del reciclaje la llevan a cabo
voluntarios que dependen de las propinas
ciudadanas y de lo que consigan vender
los recicladores de ciudad de mexico no
reciben ningún tipo de compensación del
gobierno que si se beneficia de la labor
inmensa que estos trabajadores realizan
en la ciudad de méxico más de 10.000
voluntarios participan en el servicio de
recolección de basura de manera informal
el gobierno local les llama voluntarios
porque trabajan precisamente de manera
voluntaria y con eso justifican que no
les den contrato ni salario fijo pedro
es uno de ellos entre los residuos que
separa y revende y la propina que recibe
de los residentes de la ciudad gana
entre 10 y 12 dólares al día por
propinas bueno pues que realmente es
variable
puede haber días que nos salga un poco
más a veces menos pero dependiendo
también de las posibilidades de la gente
pero hay otros recicladores que no
reciben propinas y sobreviven sólo de la
venta de residuos al no tener contacto
con la población como patricia quien
trabaja en una planta de selección que
hay gente que design award call a
trabajar en la basura pero si supieran
que hay veces que nosotros que somos que
no tenemos en donde más trabaja somos de
donde nosotros tenemos y que si no
llegaran a cerrar oa quitar la basura ya
no a miles de personas se quedarían sin
trabajo los recicladores informales no
son reconocidos por las autoridades
locales lo único que obtienen de ellas
es el permiso para trabajar para esta
población marginada poder trabajar es el
único derecho que defienden que buscamos
con el gobierno pues que ahora que
tengamos la oportunidad de poder
trabajar que es lo esencial que es lo
que necesitamos hacer un funcionamiento
una labor aquí los recicladores
voluntarios
formales de la ciudad de mexico evitan
que casi 14 por ciento de los residuos
diarios vayan a rellenos sanitarios con
ello le ahorran al gobierno más de 6
millones de dólares al año según una
estimación a partir del inventario de
residuos 2019 un aporte ambiental y
económico que no es retribuido ni
reconocido en la ciudad más grande de
américa latina- y hablamos ahora de la
situación de los alrededor de 10.000
buzos en república dominicana un nombre
que visualiza muy bien el trabajo que
hacen ellos buscan comida y materiales
reciclables dentro de los basureros de
la isla muchos de estos trabajadores son
migrantes haitianos indocumentados un
porcentaje que se calcula es del 70%
y república dominicana 10 mil
recicladores escarban en los vertederos
a cielo abierto para sobrevivir como en
el vertedero de duquesa que recibe unas
5 mil toneladas de basura del gran santo
domingo cada día estamos más con la
basura en un lado esto era basura todos
los reyes del mundo una comparación pero
también haciéndolos a los
aproximadamente 350 vertederos que
existen en el país caribeño la mayoría
de los recicladores son nacionales
haitianos como pensó que llegaron al
país en busca de mejores condiciones de
vida
eladio trabaja día y noche en el verde
yo empecé a las 6 de la mañana a las 12
yo vine a comer a la 1 me sube hasta las
11 a las 12 de la noche porque yo estoy
buscando una manera para tiene algo para
hacer y barbuda músico pensó ya tiene
seis hijos todos indocumentados como él
vive con sus compatriotas en la falda de
la gran montaña de basura que forma el
vertedero de duquesa a que nosotros
vivimos aquí
porque nosotros hago todo para que hoy
en de tal vez también no molestar a los
otros en los próximos meses los
recicladores en república dominicana
esperan la promulgación de una ley que
busca por primera vez en la historia del
país su reconocimiento por esta ley no
otorgará estatus legal a los
recicladores haitianos indocumentados
pero la situación de los recicladores en
américa latina no es única de esta
región del mundo sucede en todas partes
del planeta del otro lado del océano
atlántico en españa este trabajo aunque
algo más regulado muchas veces también
recae en las manos de inmigrantes en su
mayoría subsaharianos que intentan
subsistir gracias a la chatarra y
residuos electrónicos desechados
héctor tiene 28 años y lleva 3
recogiendo chatarra en las calles de
barcelona es una de las miles de
personas que sobreviven con esta
actividad en la que un buen día de
trabajo pueden llegar a ganar hasta 15
euros
aunque es español aquí la mayoría de los
recicladores son personas migrantes sin
papeles procedentes de áfrica
sub-sahariana
que buscan normalmente la chatarra o
gente que duerme en la calle o
extranjeros que no tienen recursos y
desde hace muchos días desde hace cinco
años atrás ahora hay mucho el doble de
gente buscando que amper héctor vende
los materiales a karim un senegalés que
llegó a españa en 2006 empezó siendo
chatarrero y ahora gestiona está
chatarrería donde cada día recibe cerca
de 200 recicladores vamos a escoger una
cara de 300 kilos el campo no va hasta
aquí cuando que la metro va a ser tú
más duro
los 365 días tú no para no es duro
encima no puedes ganar algo puede decir
que tengo dinero no es duro es muy duro
llegó aquí lo tengo papel no puede
trabajar esta población invisible
contribuye a el sector de reciclaje de
metales que mueve 10 mil millones de
euros al año en españa se estima que
aportan casi una tercera parte de la
chatarra que se recicla en cataluña no
obstante nadie sabe cuántos hay ni cuál
es su contribución a la economía que
están fuera del sistema institucional de
reciclaje pero sé consciente su
actividad dan un servicio a la sociedad
de forma gratuita porque las empresas
privadas cobran para recoger gestionar
transportar y reciclar esos materiales y
los legisladores informales de alguna
forma hacen algo parecido pero no cobran
nada del estado
y claramente hacen un servicio que
también es un servicio ambiental para
federico quemaría una opción sería
formalizar los siguiendo el ejemplo de
algunos lugares de américa latina a
través de cooperativas
y las miles de personas que sobreviven
de la chatarra en la ciudad sería un
paso adelante
como ven los desechos son un problema
global y el trabajo que hacen los que
recogen clasifican y reciclan lo que
erróneamente llamamos basura tiene un
valor monetario social y ambiental que
aún no es reconocido por las
instituciones de gobierno una labor que
podría ser algo menos difícil si desde
la ciudadanía ayudamos con una correcta
separación de los residuos antes de que
lleguen a las calles gracias por
acompañarme recuerden que pueden volver
a ver todos estos reportajes en nuestro
sitio web france24 puntocom
[Música]